nothing but nature shows dude it's a
common problem amongst roommates you
know how do you even Lee distribute the
space on the DVR you know you got to be
aware bears love nature channels so
there is a solution let's break it down
by the facts yes fact bears look awesome
on TV I'm not disputing that Winnie the
Pooh adorable the Charmin toilet paper
bears toilet paper that's a tough topic
to tackle and yet they're still cute the
Chicago Bears Barney far as fertilizer
I'm talking about different body shape
recording either way beers look awesome
on TV here is one possible solution you
can go with grab a mirror put a TV on
that we do back grab a mirror draw TV on
it bears gonna come into the room
wanting to watch TV completely unaware
this is a mirror they're gonna think
they're watching TV show about bears
they'll love it as its them and to them
that's the best looking bear this is for
serious realsies okay Bears have
short-term memory loss I should know
seemed virtually every show about bears
so what I did took a five second loop of
a nature clip how to play over and over
and over again then you know how to
share any of your DVR space pretty much
win win bears not gonna know it's seen
this show a thousand times here we go I
found the spot down within the trees and
that bears coming right in towards
here we go I found the spot down wind in
the trees and that bears coming right in
towards me here we go I found the spot
down limb in the trees and that bears
coming right in towards me watch out on
the spot down wind in the trees and that
bears coming right well then move out of
the way I'm just locked down than the
trees and had theirs coming right in
toward you should we found the spot down
wind in the trees and that bear is
coming right in then you better move